JF: Estás malgastando el tiempo
Tenemos un limitado…
LT: Justo estar con ella y ya me quita la vida.
(Risas)
JF: Todavía no han visto nada.
En fin... Disculpen.
PM: Entonces, díganme, ¿Qué buscan en una amiga?
LT: Busco que tenga cierto sentido del humor,
que sea osada,
que sea cercana, que tenga reglas,
a alguien que tenga algo de pasión por el planeta,
a alguien decente con sentido de la justicia
y que crea que merezco la pena.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
JF: Saben, estuve pensando esta mañana
en que ni siquiera sé qué es lo que haría sin mis amigas.
Eso significa: “Tengo amigas, luego existo”.
(Risas)
JF: De verdad, es así.
Existo porque tengo a mis amigas. Ellas…
Tú eres una de ellas.
No sé tú, pero en fin…
(Risas)
Ya saben, ellas me hacen más fuerte, más inteligente,
más valiente.
Ellas me dan una palmada en el hombro cuando necesito orientación.
Y muchas de ellas son mucho más jóvenes que yo, también.
¿Saben? Eso es genial-- LT: Gracias.
(Risas)
JF: No, es cierto, te incluyo, porque escuchen, Uds. saben…
es genial tener a alguien cerca con quien jugar y de quien aprender
cuando te acercas al final.
Me estoy acercando... Estaré allí antes que tú.
LT: Me alegra tenerte envejeciendo junto a mí.
(Risas)
JF: Te estoy mostrando el rumbo
LT: Bueno, sí lo haces.
PM: Al hacerse mayores,
y atravesar distintos tipos y estilos de vida,
¿qué hacen para conservar la amistad rica y viva?
LT: Tenemos que usar muchas…
JF: Debo decir que ella no me invita mucho.
LT: Tengo que usar muchas redes sociales…
Calla un poco. Entonces…
(Risas)
Reviso mis correos y mis mensajes de texto
para encontrarme con mis amigas,
así poder responder rápidamente,
porque sé que necesitan mi consejo.
(Risas)
Necesitan mi apoyo,
Porque muchas de mis amigas son escritoras, activistas o actrices
y tú eres tres en una…
y una larga lista de otras frases descriptivas,
y quiero verlas tan pronto como sea posible,
quiero que sepan que estoy allí para Uds.
JF: ¿Usas emoticonos?
LT: Oh... JF: ¿No?
LT: Es embarazoso. JF: Yo sí.
LT: No. Yo escribo…
escribo palabras de felicidad, felicitaciones
y tristeza.
JF: ¿Escribes todo?
LT: Escribo cada letra.
(Risas)
JF: Así es de purista.
Saben, al envejecer,
entendí mejor la importancia de la amistad,
y por so me esfuerzo
para tener encuentros sin que pase demasiado tiempo.
Leo mucho.
Así que, como Lily sabe muy bien,
los libros que me gustan, se los envío a amigas
LT: Al saber que estaríamos aquí hoy
me enviaste muchos libros sobre mujeres y la amistad,
y me sorprendió ver tantos libros,
cuanta investigación se ha hecho recientemente…
JF: ¿Y estabas agradecida? LT: Estaba agradecida.
(Risas)
PM: Y…
LT: Espera, esto es muy importante porque es otro ejemplo
de cuántas mujeres han sido ignoradas, olvidadas y marginadas.
Ha habido muy poca investigación sobre nosotras,
aún ofreciéndonos voluntarias muchas veces.
JF: Eso es muy cierto.
(Risas)
LT: Es muy fascinante, y todas estarán interesadas en esto.
La Escuela Médica de Harvard ha demostrado
que las mujeres que tienen amigas íntimas
tienen menos probabilidad de desarrollar deficiencias…
deficiencias físicas al envejecer,
y es probable que se vean mucho más vitales, entusiastas…
JF: Y más longevas...
LT: Con vidas más felices.
JF: Vivimos 5 años más que los hombres.
LT: Creo que cambiaría los años por alegría.
(Risas)
LT: Pero lo más importante es que encontraron...
los resultados eran tan fascinantes y concluyentes…
Los investigadores descubrieron
que no tener amigas íntimas es devastador para la salud,
tanto como fumar o tener sobrepeso.
JF: Y hay algo más, también…
LT: Ya dije mi parte, así que…
(Risas)
JF: Bien, escucha mi parte, porque hay algo adicional.
Porque solo… por años, décadas…
Ellos solo investigaron a hombres al intentar entender el estrés,
solo hace poco investigaron qué pasa a las mujeres cuando están estresadas,
y resulta que cuando están estresadas… las mujeres,
nuestros cuerpos liberan oxitocina.
Que es una hormona de bienestar que calma y reduce el estrés.
Que también se incrementa al estar con amigas.
Y creo que esa es una razón por la que vivimos más.
Y me apeno por los hombres porque ellos no tienen eso.
La testosterona en ellos disminuye los efectos de la oxitocina.
LT: Cuando tú, Dolly y yo hicimos el film “9 a 5”…
JF: Oh
LT: Reíamos, sí, nos reíamos tanto,
vimos que teníamos tanto en común y éramos tan diferentes.
Aquí está ella, como una reina de Hollywood,
y yo como una ruda niña de Detroit,
ella como una niña sureña de un pueblecillo de Tennessee,
y descubrimos que congeniábamos tanto como mujeres,
y debemos tener…
nos hemos reído tanto como para sumar al menos una década a nuestras vidas
JF: Creo que… cruzamos mucho las piernas.
(Risas)
Si saben a lo que me refiero.
LT: Creo que todas sabemos a lo que te refieres.
(Risas)
PM: Están sumando décadas a sus vidas justo ahora.
Así que, entre los libros que Jane nos envió sobre la amistad
había uno de una mujer que admiramos, la hermana Joan Chittister
quien dijo sobre la amistad
que las amigas no son solo una cuestión social,
son una cuestión espiritual.
¿Ven a sus amigas en un nivel espiritual?
¿Agregan algo espiritual a sus vidas?
LT: Espiritual… Creo sin duda en eso.
Porque… especialmente a las personas que conoces bien,
personas con las que has pasado tiempo…
ves su esencia espiritual en ellas
su emotividad, su vulnerabilidad.
Hay, de hecho, algo de amor, un elemento de amor en la relación.
logras ver el fondo de sus almas.
PM: ¿Crees eso, Jane?..
LT: Pero tengo poderes especiales.
JF: Existe toda clase de amigas.
Hay amigas de negocios y de fiestas,
¡Tengo muchas de ellas!
(Risas)
Pero el tipo de amistades que producen la oxitocina tienen…
algo espiritual porque nos abren el corazón, ¿cierto?
Ya saben, nos sensibilizan. Y…
descubro que he llorado en muchos casos con mis amigas íntimas.
No porque esté triste sino porque estoy conmovida e inspirada por ellas.
LT: Y ya saben una de Uds. ya se va pronto.
(Risas)
PM: Bueno, dos estamos sentadas aquí, Lily, ¿a quién te refieres?
Y siempre creo que cuando las mujeres hablan sobre sus amigas,
los hombres siempre parecen algo intrigados.
¿Cuáles son las diferencias, en su opinión,
entre las amistades con hombres y amistades con mujeres?
JF: Hay mucha diferencia,
creo que debemos tener mucha empatía para con los hombres…
(Risas)
Ellos no tienen lo que nosotras.
Y pueda ser porque mueren más pronto.
(Risas)
Tengo mucha compasión por los hombres,
Porque las mujeres, no bromeo, nosotras…
las relaciones femeninas, nuestras amistades son abiertas, profundas.
Son sinceras.
Arriesgamos nuestra vulnerabilidad… algo que lo hombres no hacen.
Quiero decir, cuántas veces he preguntado: ¿Está bien así?
¿Me equivoqué en eso?
PM: Lo estás haciendo genial.
(Risas)
JF: Pero, en fin, nosotras hacemos preguntas como esas
a nuestras amigas
y los hombres no.
La gente describe las relaciones femeninas como personales,
mientras que las masculinas son más impersonales.
LT: Es decir, la mayoría del tiempo ellos no quieren expresar sus emociones,
Ellos procuran sepultar sus emociones más profundas.
Y, esa es la idea general y convencional.
Ellos prefirieren marcharse a sus cuevas y ver un juego o golpear pelotas de golf,
o hablar sobre deporte, cacería, autos o tener sexo.
Es decir, es justo el tipo de… es una actitud más masculina.
JF: Quisiste decir... LT: Ellos hablan de sexo.
Quise decir que podrían tener sexo
si ellos pudieran conseguir a alguien en sus cuevas y…
(Risas)
JF: Saben, sin embargo, lo que encuentro interesante…
y una vez más, los psicólogos no lo sabían hasta hace poco…
que los hombres nacen tan sociales como las mujeres.
Si miran los vídeos de los niños y niñas recién nacidos,
verán que los niños tanto como las niñas,
buscan el contacto visual materno,
ya saben, buscan ese intercambio interpersonal de energía.
Cuando la madre esquiva la mirada, se verá la consternación en el bebé
incluso el bebé incluso llora.
Ellos necesitan ese vínculo.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Por qué al crecer, surge este cambio?
Y la respuesta es la cultura patriarcal,
que dice a los niños y a jóvenes
que intentar relacionarse y ser emocionales con alguien es afeminado.
Que un hombre verdadero no pide orientación ni expresa necesidad,
no van al médico si se sienten mal.
Ellos no piden ayuda.
Hay una frase que me gusta,
“Los hombres temen que un “nosotros” borre su 'Yo' ”.
Ya saben, su identidad.
Mientras que el sentido de ser femenino siempre ha sido algo poroso.
Pero el “Nosotras” es nuestra gracia redentora,
es lo que nos hace fuertes.
No es que nosotras seamos mejores que ellos,
es solo que nosotras no tenemos que probar masculinidad.
LT: Y, bueno…
JF: Esa es una cita de Gloria Steinem.
Por ello, podemos expresar humanidad. LT: Sé quien es Gloria Steinem.
JF: Sé que conoces quien es, pero creo que es una…
(Risas)
No, pero es una gran frase, creo.
“No somos mejores que ellos es solo que no tenemos que probar masculinidad”.
Y eso es muy importante.
LT: Pero los hombres están muy sometidos por la cultura
a sentirse cómodos con el patriarcado.
Y debemos hacer que suceda algo diferente.
JF: Las amigas son como una fuente renovable de poder.
LT: Bueno, eso es lo fascinante de este tema.
Es porque nuestras amistades…
las amigas, son un paso a nuestra hermandad,
y la hermandad puede ser una fuerza poderosa,
para dar al mundo…
para convertirlo en lo que como debería ser…
Las cosas que los humanos desesperadamente necesitan.
PM: Por eso estamos hablando de ello,
porque las amigas son,
como dijiste, Jane,
una fuente renovable de poder.
¿Así que, cómo usamos ese poder?
JF: Las mujeres son el factor demográfico de crecimiento más rápido del mundo,
especialmente las mujeres de edad.
Y si aprovechamos ese poder, podemos cambiar el mundo.
Y ¿saben qué? Lo necesitamos.
(Aplausos)
Y necesitamos hacerlo pronto.
Y una de las cosas que necesitamos hacer…
y podemos hacerlo como mujeres…
por un lado, es establecer los estándares de consumo
necesitamos consumir menos.
Nosotras en el mundo occidental necesitamos consumir menos
y cuando compremos, debemos comprar cosas hechas en la localidad,
cuando compremos comida, debemos comprarla cultivada en el lugar.
Necesitamos evitar depender de los servicios públicos.
Debemos independizarnos de los combustibles fósiles
y de sus compañías...
Los Exxons, gasolinas Shell y esos chicos malos…
porque sí lo son... ellos
nos dirán que no podremos lograrlo sin remontarnos antes a la Edad de Piedra.
Dirán que aún no existen alternativas,
y eso no es verdad.
Ahora mismo, hay países en el mundo
que viven principalmente de energía renovable y les va bien.
Y nos dicen que si evitamos los combustibles fósiles
vamos a estar de regreso en la Edad de Piedra,
y de hecho, si empezamos a usar energía renovable,
y no perforamos en el Ártico, y no perforamos...
LT: Oh, Dios.
JF: Y no perforamos en las arenas petrolíferas de Alberta...
Cierto.
Pues seremos…
habrá más democracia y más empleos y más bienestar,
y son las mujeres quienes van a liderar el rumbo.
LT: Tal vez sea el momento para empezar un tercer movimiento feminista
con nuestra hermandad alrededor del mundo,
con mujeres que no vemos, mujeres que quizá nunca conozcamos,
pero nos unimos juntas en este camino,
porque…
como dijo Aristóteles…
muchas personas…
La gente moriría sin amigos hombres.
Y la palabra clave aquí es “hombres”
Porque ellos pensaban que la amistad debería ser entre iguales
y las mujeres no eran consideradas iguales…
JF: Los griegos, no creían siquiera que teníamos alma
LT: No, exactamente. Eso muestra cuán limitado fue Aristóteles.
(Risas)
Y esperen, no, aquí está la mejor parte.
Ya saben, los hombres necesitan a las mujeres ahora.
El planeta necesita a las mujeres.
La constitución estadounidense necesita a las mujeres.
No estamos siquiera en la Constitución.
JF: Te refieres a la Enmienda de Igualdad de Derechos
LT: Correcto.
Justice Ginsberg dijo algo como…
toda constitución que ha sido escrita desde el final de la 2º Guerra Mundial
incluía una disposición que hacía a las mujeres ciudadanas de igual status,
pero la nuestra no.
Ese sería un buen punto para empezar.
Muy, muy elemental...
JF: Cierto.
(Aplausos)
Y la igualdad de género, es como una marea
alzaría todos los botes, no solo a mujeres.
PM: Necesitamos nuevos modelos de roles sobre cómo hacer eso.
Cómo ser amigos,
cómo pensar sobre nuestro poder en diferentes formas,
como consumidoras,
como ciudadanas del mundo,
y esto es lo que hace a Jane y Lily
un modelo de cómo las mujeres pueden ser amigas…
por un largo tiempo,
incluso si ocasionalmente están en desacuerdo.
Gracias.
Gracias a ambas.
(Aplausos)
JF: Gracias.
LT: Gracias
JF: Gracias
(Aplausos)